in the last video we saw that if we were
to take the sum
from i equals 0
to
n
of i squared
that this could be equal to and we did
it in two videos it was a little bit
hairy but we powered through this is
equal to one-third
n to the third power
let me write it a little bit cleaner
than that
n to the third power plus one-half
n squared plus 1 6
1 6 n
and that is absolutely true
but you might have seen a different
formula for this it doesn't look like
that and so what i want to do is now
manipulate this a little bit
algebraically to come up with another
formula that's typically seen for this
sum
so the first thing that we might realize
is well let's what's what happens if we
factor out a 1 6 n
so this is going to be equal to let's
factor out this right over here
so that would be equal to one
sixth
n
times
so let's see one third divided by one
sixth that's the same thing as one third
times six so that's going to be equal to
so this right over here is going to be
equal to 2
n squared and you can verify it 1 6
times 2 is 2 6 or 1 3 n times n squared
is n to the third power
now one half divided by 1 6 is the same
thing as one half times 6 which is 3
so this term right over here is going to
be plus
3 times
3 times n and then finally you have this
term right over here which is just going
to be equal to one
and now we're faced now we're faced with
factoring this thing right over here
now you could do this well let's let's
do this by
let's let's factor by grouping this and
remember when you factor it by grouping
you want to essentially break you want
to break this into two numbers where the
product of those two numbers the product
of those two numbers is equal to the
product of two times one
and the obvious thing is well two times
one is two if i break this into two and
one if i break this three into two and
one well two times one is definitely two
times one so let me rewrite this i'm
just factoring by grouping here nothing
super fancy so if i rewrite this as 2n
squared
2n squared plus
plus
n
plus 2n
plus 1. plus 1. so this is all the stuff
in this parentheses right over here
well this part right over here we can
factor out an n so this is going to be
equal let me just write the 1 6 n here
so you know what i'm doing
1 6 then so if we factor out an n right
over here
we would have
n
times
2n
n times
n plus 1
2 n
plus 1
plus 1. so that's what's in green right
over here that's this part right over
here
and then what i have
what i have here
i could write this as plus 1
times 2n plus 1
one times let me do that same color so 1
times
2n
plus 1
plus
1.
and so now you can factor out a 2n plus
1 and this thing simplifies to
1 6 n
times 2n plus 1. i'm just factoring out
a 2n plus 1. i'm just factoring out a 2n
plus 1 and then you're going to have n
plus if you take a if you factor a 2n
plus 1 out of each of these terms you're
going to have just an n and a 1. so 1 6
times n
times 2n plus 1
2n
plus 1
times
n plus 1
n
and plus 1. and if this was a little bit
confusing what i did here i encourage
you to review the videos on factoring by
grouping
times n plus one
and another way to re we could rewrite
this we could write this whole thing as
being equal to and maybe i'll write in
this green color that we started off
with this is the same thing as
this is the same thing and i'll write
well we could i could write it as n
times
n plus 1
times 2n plus 1
all of that
over 6. so this expression is equivalent
to this expression and it's equivalent
to this value right over here so
whichever one you find to be a little
bit easier to think about